Dave's back and Dave's back in a big way
here's some things that Davis said he
says he has a 600 million dollar real
estate portfolio that is fully paid off
so 600 million dollars of real estate
Equity that he that he owns that's kind
of insane his media Empire which is like
you know the combination of his
um radio shows and then all of the
financial like courses training seminars
all that stuff that they do outside of
that
he says on their website makes 300
million a year in Revenue
[Music]
all right we're live um what do you want
to talk about today I've got a bunch of
good topics let me bring up one juicy
one
last year or two years ago you asked me
a question you're like who do you admire
I think you asked me that and I said
this guy named Laird Hamilton Laird
Hamilton is this like beautiful surfer
dude he's like in his 50s now basically
he's beautiful like we get a we gotta
acknowledge that he's got like beautiful
wavy blonde hair and like a nice skin
and he's pretty ripped for his age and
he always was ripped he's like this
tough guy that surfs big waves and
whatever
he launched this thing called where you
make fun of me because I'm dreaming
about this guy I don't even need to make
a joke you've done it all yourself here
now like this is like this is like
objective like I'm just stating facts
here he's a human Ken doll he launched
this thing called layered superfoods
have you heard of that it's like a
coffee creamer that's made out of like
coconut I think right
uh anyway
I uh they took the company public I
don't know why they did that but they
took it public at a 300 or 400 million
dollar market cap at the time they were
doing 50 million in in Revenue
look up the company now can you look can
you go and look up the do you know what
their market cap is today let me find it
I know what it was yesterday I don't
know what it is today why would it be so
different oh wow nine million dollars
nine million dollars so this company uh
I if you click uh I have a bunch of
notes here you can click them and read
them but basically this company they
sell like a fair amount of like coffee
creamer so yesterday I think it was 8.8
million dude so listen they have 20
million in cash no debt at all their
revenue is decreasing so it like in Q3
it was 8.8 million from Q3 of last year
was 10.9 million so what's that like a
like a like a four times eight so it's a
48 million dollar or 50 million dollar a
year business but it's declining they're
they have good decent gross profit they
have an okay balance sheet but like the
business for some reason it's valued so
low I'd have to dive deep into it and
really look at the numbers but it's kind
of ridiculous right so you were talking
about wanting to buy a company you've
said this before
this is your target dude we get to hang
out with layered him sounds like it's
your target dude that sounds like this
is like you know those things where it's
like we're auctioning off a date with
Laird Hamilton it's like a hug why don't
you buy this yeah you you just bought
yourself a nine million dollar hug
foreign
dude why is this why is this company you
haven't looked at this but why is this
company so cheap what is going on I
don't know how much debt they have but
none I said that so I read their report
they had their uh Q3 reports 21 million
dollars in cash zero debt zero debt so I
never understand when when companies
trade this far below their just cash
value because you know the obvious
question then is why do you not buy this
thing for 15 million and just wind it
down and distribute the 20 million to
yourself uh and make five million
dollars you know like or sell the
inventory they have like 13 million or
something in inventory
okay uh interesting so yeah so I mean I
haven't looked at this because you just
mentioned it but um but yeah there's a
bunch of these right now that are like
this uh there was one the other day that
I that I saw that was kind of in the
same same bucket but there's a bunch of
stocks that are down like 95 right now
that seem like you know interesting
takeover targets and uh we have a friend
who was interested in doing this and so
I made a list of like 10 I was like
here's 10 that I think you could buy is
this friend aggressive
is it aggressive friend I got it I know
yeah okay I know which friend it is
how tight is that by the way just to be
able to say this is an aggressive friend
and you're like yeah I know who it is
does this friend would this friend say
to a a battling entrepreneur your
business is one Google away from me
ruining you
baby
they usually don't say things to to
their to their faces like that they uh
they're more just like another under
like you know those sharks that swim
only under the water they don't put the
fin out he's more like that got it but
like wish.com was the was the other
example that that I had recently seen
that was like this which is uh wish you
know pretty big brand name because they
spent billions of dollars marketing this
thing 10 billion dollar market cap at
one point now 360 million so 10 billion
to 360 million has seven 700 million in
cash with no liabilities
um
you know so so I don't know exactly uh
you know I don't I don't know exactly
how you can buy these things I think
that's the the challenge is like to
actually acquire the majority in doing
so you would push the price up because
people would know what you're doing so I
think you'd have to make like a tender
offer at a specific price that's like
you know whatever whatever you know some
something above but you know the board
will just reject it they'll say we have
more cash than that on the on the
balance sheet so we don't need to sell
at this price so I don't know exactly
mechanically how somebody does this I
don't know if this is like uh you know
fantasy math where you're like dude what
if Shaq was in the you know the 100
meter race he could just knock people
over it's like that's not it doesn't
make sense it's not helping to work in
the real world so you know this like
idea of like public company takeovers is
not something that I understand you know
is that like a drunken conversation
you've had which is can check when the
100 meter dash you know the one thing
about this podcast is the number of on
the Fly analogies you have to create
it just really brings it's that's a
different skill that's a different
muscle and uh yeah that muscle's not not
so strong yet I'm still working on it so
anyway layered superfood interesting
company that I was that I was iron
layered
maybe a little less hot in my book now
because this company is worth only eight
million it's a 300. now he's just a
really hot fit guy before he was hot fit
and Rich so he lost the Third Leg of the
stool yeah he's still famous and famous
Trump's wealth in most cases in most
people's eyes but
anyway all right well let me tell you
let me tell you about somebody who is
Rich
and somebody who is famous
but he's not hot can I tell you okay
um
are you familiar with Dave Ramsey yeah
yeah yeah very tell me what you know
about Dave Ramsey and I'm Gonna Fill In
some gaps for you so Dave uh he's like a
personal finance Guru he's based out of
Franklin Tennessee he's in his 70s
probably now he started as a radio host
where it was just like Dave Ramsey like
show and then he parlayed that into like
the Dave Ramsey Network so now he has
like four or 500 employees based out of
Franklin Tennessee and they do like 400
or 500 million a year in Revenue where
they sell like personal finance stuff a
lot of his I think he's pretty
controversial because a lot of his Like
rules his lot of his personal finance
rules are based in like biblical Like
rules he also bleeds in like zero debt
and he uh he's pretty conservative so
people who aren't conservative aren't
into him
okay well you do a lot more than I would
have guessed so yeah I guess the
segment's over
like Franklin Tennessee how do you know
this stuff what's going on here he also
bought all of his buildings without any
debt so he owns like a campus in
Franklin Tennessee yeah yeah so I'm
sorry but did I I don't know you know
well
spitted my food but all right I'm still
hungry so let's go
um so Dave he's 62 years old uh he was a
realtor turned radio host and yeah he's
from Tennessee uh so basically what
happened is by his mid-20s this is like
back in the 80s so back but dude you
didn't know who Dolly Parton was and
she's also a Tennessee person so like
yeah I guess I I lesson learned I'm not
coming at you with any Tennessee trivia
anymore
so by his mid-20s he's got like a four
million dollar property portfolio real
estate portfolio and it's kicking off
some cash maybe like five percent a year
cash or cash return so he's making 250k
a year off his real estate portfolio at
that stage
um at this time 1988 so the you know the
year I'm born his bank basically revokes
his line of credit and
um demands that he pays it back and he
couldn't sell fast enough so he gets
foreclosed on and declares bankruptcy
this is like the trauma of why he's like
um don't notice debt no debt he's like
dead bad debt bad why because I burned
my hand on the debt stove before this
and so he's like he's got no money now
he's you know his marriage is on the
Rocks he says he could be you know
considering committing suicide uh but
you know he gets back on his feet so
this is kind of like his story so
anyways
today fast forward to today
Dave's back and Dave's back in a big way
here's some things that Davis said he
says he has a 600 million dollar real
estate portfolio that is fully paid off
so 600 million dollars of real estate
Equity that he that he owns that's kind
of insane his media Empire which is like
you know the combination of his
um radio shows and then all of the
financial like courses training seminars
all that stuff that they do outside of
that
he says on their website makes 300
million a year in Revenue I believe it
which is absurd I don't know any people
that go to that what's that no you know
people anybody that goes so dude in the
South it's a thing so I had Texas
employees and like if you're just like a
normal couple where each employee makes
or each wife and husband makes like 60
or 70 grand a year you'll like pay to go
to like a Dave Ramsey like he trains
these financial advisors and they host
seminars and you'll go to this like five
day weeknights thing where it's like
instead of Bible study it's like we
teach you how to like save and like
invest like yeah it's like Jesus on the
front and a p l on the back this new
remix Bible I love it
his company Ramsay Solutions is just
absolute Juggernaut it's insane so so
okay let's break down the media side so
he launches this thing in 1992 and
basically he's done content for 30 years
about the same seven steps it's like
this guy's just been talking about the
same thing I don't know how he feels
like hours I've never listened to like a
full thing but I don't know he feels
like four hours a day of radio it's a
good show just saying the same thing
every time like oh you got debt pay that
off right so he's got these seven
tenants so here's his seven tenants all
right uh number one you establish an
emergency fund of a thousand dollars
that's your first baby step to Financial
Freedom and Jesus Bliss second one you
want to pay off all your non-housing
debts ASAP starting with the smallest
one so that he calls this a snowball so
don't pay off like the highest rate
interest just pay off the smallest thing
you can just to get momentum all right I
like that then you increase your
emergency phone to three to six months
of income then you put 15 into a 401k or
IRA then you start your five five you
know 529 plans or whatever like the
college funds uh you pay off your
mortgage and then you now you're fully
paid off you got your you got your
safety net now you start to build wealth
and so
that's his like those are his seven
steps his company Ramsey Solutions is a
biblically based Common Sense Financial
education Media Company
[Laughter]
hey YouTube editor play that clip of
like you know Jay-Z the first time he
hears like the intro to like you know
um
Timberland's playing him a beat and he's
like oh that's nice
that's how I feel when I hear the
biblically based Common Sense Financial
education Media company so that's
amazing then he's got you said you
talked about this like uh Nat I guess
Tennessee like Empire he's got he's got
a thousand employees working there he
owns all the real estate so he's got a
he owns I don't know this is correct the
researcher might have just gone off the
rails dude he owns a lot he owns a lot
he owns two office towers that are 200
million square feet that sounds absurd
that's I don't that's too much not real
um you know we got to get the researcher
you know stop drinking your your product
that you were selling from from college
yeah
um but but he's got basically like you
know a 50 000 square foot Event Center
he's got 60 Acres of just like property
land that he bought for 10 million
dollars so owns a bunch of land uses
that land to run his kind of like you
know you know Common Sense biblical
Financial Empire out in Tennessee
he's doing his show for three hours a
day five days a week people call in and
they're basically like all right Dave
you know long time listener first time
caller uh and you know there's part of
it that's sort of like my first million
I actually think we should steal his
stick uh which is he goes yeah they'll
call him they'll be like I I'm worth
four million dollars and be like how old
are you I'd be like I'm 32 years old
would be like fantastic 34 minutes he's
writing notes this whole time and then
he'll be like um how much debt and
they're like yeah I got my mortgage you
know 800 000 and you could just hear him
like
just hit someone with a little a little
tisk uh you know it's like dad's
disappointed in me and then he'll be
like you know I'm making this much a
year I put this much away and blah blah
blah and then he gives him Financial
advice which is kind of the same with
financial advice every single time but
somehow people like get really into this
uh this thing
and then the other things he does which
are just these hilarious segments that
he has uh so he's got everyday
millionaires so somebody calls in he
interviews somebody that's that's worth
a million dollars but then he has and
this is good
the debt free scream have you seen this
before
well I I used to think that it was like
the equivalent of ringing a bell like
there yeah he had like a he had a thing
where people would call him be like I
finally paid off my debt and they like
celebrate it they celebrate it with the
debt-free scream
I think there's things we could learn
from this guy I think we should steal
some of this guy's shtick
um and and so he's he's really got
something going here anyway so you wait
you've never heard of him no no I've
heard him I didn't realize how rich he
was I just thought he was like someone's
dad that gives basic Financial advice
because he's got the dad Vibe he's got
the vibe of someone who calls diabetes
diabetes like that's the you know what I
mean like like the thing above your head
is definitely a rough to him not a roof
uh he's got that type of 100 on the
diabetes thing yeah
and the podcast
I need to now laugh for 30 minutes I
don't want to do the rest of the fight
that's that's his Vibe he's a little
judgmental too and he's like uh this is
the only way yeah so he's not
opinionated I mean he's Dr Phil for
money he's exactly you know he's got his
thing which is like this is how you do
things and he's like a guy with a big
belly who wears suspenders Vibes you
know what I'm talking about like like
that like that type of vibe so he's not
wrong it just sometimes is energy I
think is a little bit judgmental yeah
yeah exactly
um yeah exactly okay I was gonna make a
bunch of jokes about his look but I
decided to
turn the other cheek or whatever he
would want me to do so his show is like
nationally syndicated on radio which I
think is like the hack so 20 million
people a week apparently listen to this
I don't know how they it's huge but like
when I basically Drive I would listen to
it all the time
yeah of course you did of course you're
his target market
um so you know he's basically carried
about like 600 radio Affiliates I think
that's amazing so he's got his books
he's got 23 best-selling books I don't
know what that even means uh that's like
their that's what do you think that
means that's their personality so he's
got like his daughter does it now and
he's got these other people like Ken and
Dr John and like all these other people
that he's created as other other kind of
personalities or Brands they're called
the Ramsay personalities
um so he's got the man anyways
live speaking courses they got an app
they have you know all kinds of stuff
it's kind of crazy so let me give you
some of his some of his tweets some of
his tweets are quotes I want you to
react to him with a hallelujah or a uh
no brother not for me all right that's
the first one
if you're working and paying off debt
the only time you should see the inside
of a restaurant is if you're working
there
A Hallelujah I'll give you that A
half-hearted Hallelujah that's fine if
you come to work late and they're paying
you you're stealing don't steal and
expect to be promoted Hallelujah I'm a
capitalist Pig there's nothing socialist
about me I'd put my my receptionist on
straight commission if I could figure
out a way 100 Hallelujah I love that one
all right Dave Matthew now you're
talking about my style all right here we
go
um
if somebody calls in and they got more
debt than their annual income he'll say
that's a small shovel and a big hole
I love that I love that Dave
um okay then he also says uh he quotes
he quotes the Proverbs 22 7 and states
the rich rule over the poor and the
borrower is a slave to the lender
no I think that that's wrong I think
that you can use debt like effectively
to help you sure
um Terry's a gun guys guys guys awesome
guys awesome and uh I did not he carries
a gun
Carries a Gun he carries a a 45 with
hollow point bullets according to
himself you know what a 45 is that's a
pretty big round
uh yeah that's the biggest round I know
of
that's a big that's a big round
um yeah so anyways fascinating guy in
his 60s that like I I could not believe
his Empire generates this much cash 300
million a year is a is a pretty absurd
number for this dude and he's been doing
that for decades it just shows you how
big the Tony Robbins Empire must be like
Tony Robbins says this thing during his
his things he goes my business is
bringing over 500 million dollars a year
um but I didn't know what that means
because like it's like when a Ad Agency
guy's like oh I've spent over 100
million dollars you know uh you know 100
we've generated over 100 million dollars
in Revenue it's like no dude you took
the company gave you a budget you pushed
spend at the average normal rate
um and you've done this for 10 years and
you added up their total revenue number
like that that's not you
um or like you know a lot of people will
say they own 100 million dollars of real
estate with and like okay cool you know
so what's your equity in that and
they're like well it's 80 bank loan so
the bank loans 80 of it and then of the
20 down I syndicated that out and so I
got a three percent broker Commission on
it and I owned two percent of the of the
property it's like okay let's be a
little more real about it so to me it
was pretty stunning to hear that he's
got a 600 million fully paid off real
estate portfolio and a 300 million
dollar year business up higher if those
numbers are to be believed I could also
see this being totally full of by
the way no no no no no no it's not full
of it's definitely not full of
I don't have any way to verify it but
like I know his reach and I know that
that is like very attainable to God yeah
dude did you just read a book on on
Words Christians say no dude it's the
flooding
a little special something in me today
either I'm gonna get canceled or I'm
gonna get a good laugh out of you and
that is worth the risk to me have you
been south of the Mason-Dixon Line man
have you like been in the midwest
apparently not you went to Duke but
Duke's not really the south I mean my
skin color is allowed south of the
Mason-Dixon line I don't know what that
is have you hung out in like Tennessee
and Missouri Kansas Alabama you've never
hung out in these places have you
look out is there something to do there
have you ever even been I drove through
but I came to California I had to step
through the mud of the Midwest
dude you gotta go man Oklahoma all jokes
aside so you know I got myself a
southern street cred
ential certificate just because you've
been to the airport don't mean you've
been there that's like with the thing
you got to get out man even just go to
like this sounds very
get out is right if you're in Tennessee
you do got to get out dude just go
exactly you're a good drive an hour and
a half north and go to a Walmart and
just chill and just watch what people
purchase and why do they buy you got to
get out of your little San Francisco
bubble my man you got to get out and see
like there's 350 million people in
America this is I gotta tell you a funny
story yesterday I went to go I left my
house for a meeting so I go meet
somebody very interesting I might tell
you about this later uh in the pot so I
go meet somebody very interesting and
who
um I'm deciding if I want to save it to
do a bigger thing or he's going to come
on as a guest or maybe I'll tell you
about it I haven't decided yet so do I
know them no uh I don't think because
they're they're not in your world right
like you know about Dolly Parton you
don't know about like you know the NBA
uh you know so it's like a different
different yeah another big baseball guy
so uh uh brought by my wife and kids
came with me it's like kind of kind of a
long drive I was like oh why don't we
all drive down there together uh you
know Nanny's out sick just drive down
together we'll go to McDonald's
afterwards and my kids love like getting
a Happy Meal toy so it's like we'll do
that there's none around us we'll go go
out there so we go to this McDonald's
kind of out you know I've driven an hour
away we're going to this McDonald's out
there and um
there's a so I'm wait I'm like waiting
and what I think is the line but you
know McDonald's is kind of ambiguous
with the line there's not like they
don't have like the airport order at the
checkout or you have the self-checkout
too no well there's like self-checkouts
like to the left and the right and then
there's like the cashier in the front
and there's some people just waiting for
their order you don't know if they're in
line or not like you don't know what's
going on and so there's a guy in front
of me and uh the cashier's just like
waiting and I was like I was like oh uh
you can go she's ready and then the
cashier just goes he doesn't have money
[Laughter]
and I was like I thought it was such a
funny thing for the lady to say now he
doesn't have money like that's so funny
to me like so outrageous of a comment
like why did she have to say it like
that but it was like the most direct
line of the answer like not like no you
can go ahead he's not he's not ready or
he's not ordering
[Laughter]
take someone's food that didn't show up
or something I don't know what he's
doing I was in the bathroom at the
airport recently and uh there was like
there's like a line for the urinal but
there was also like a line for the
Stalls and the guy walks up to me and he
looks at the the stall and he looks at
me and goes
[Laughter]
[Music]
you waiting to poop
yeah dude
and then you have to answer too right
like you can't not answer at that point
oh my God why am I why am I paying it
playing into this it was just a dead
face it's just looking at he goes you
went to poop
and I was like a 12 year old I don't
know why I thought that was so bad
um oh my God uh I have another business
you wanna talk about business or no yeah
yeah yeah of course
um
we're idiots
um uh by the way if you're listening in
Austin
um we're doing an event well actually
we're doing two events I think the
second one's not confirmed the second
one is Sean and I doing a live pod late
April we're gonna have more on that
right bro that's it's confirmed we're
doing it we just don't know the venue
yet we don't know the venue yet we need
to know is it gonna be 300 people a
thousand people or three thousand people
that's that's kind of the only thing
that that we're missing here is how many
of you will show up to this live show in
Austin where we can we're gonna we're
gonna put on a little show we're gonna
meet and greet have some fun maybe do a
little private dinner uh with some
people afterwards so I think we should
we're gonna do that end of April
where do they go to like sign up for
that we'll put the link in the
description here yeah and then go to and
what's our website called mfmpod.com
mfmpod.com which is like
myfirstmilionpod.com and then we're
we're doing another one this one is not
a Wii this is a me Sean's not coming to
this one it's just a casual hangout
session we're doing that
uh mid when is when is that on a week
mid-march is it
March 15th so Wednesday March 15th it's
free you can just show up and we're just
gonna hang out and you can find that
also on mfmpod.com or by the time this
episode's air airs I will have tweeted
it so you can go to my uh Twitter handle
the stamp part and see it Sam I'm in a
great mood can I tell you why yes
I
did something that I forgot is an
amazing tactic and technique so I'm
gonna say it out loud here so other
people could do it but also it's a
reminder to myself to do it have you
ever heard of something called flooding
no is that when you text someone a lot
of no I have no idea it could be a lot
of things don't Urban Dictionary it's
probably something weird but uh here's
here's how I learned about it uh Tony
Robbins talked about this thing so he
goes somebody asked them they go what's
a like you know marriage like advice or
a thing you do in your marriage that
like you know uh makes it better and he
he basically had like two stories that I
really loved I'll skip the first one for
now I've told it I teach it my course
but I'll skip that one for now the
second one that he had said was he goes
about once a month we'll do something
called flooding which is basically us we
sit down on the on the couch you know
like we're about to watch Netflix or
something else but instead of just
mindlessly vegging out to some TV we
watch videos or photos uh we go of some
part of our past some some era of our
past so maybe like this vacation that we
went on or our wedding or whatever and
you basically you'll get this flood of
memories and emotion that are linked and
anchored to those moments
uh but most people don't like revisit it
in a kind of like in in a like like a
conscious way or an intentional way like
this and
I do this in two ways um one I'll do it
with like life photos or memories uh
videos or videos or photos the second
one is and this is the one I did before
this which is why blog post or something
pull up a bunch of videos that were
really funny to me back in like the day
back in college like back when YouTube
was like the new
and like you know things would go viral
but it was like yeah e-bombs world like
things would go viral and like everybody
knew about that that video you know
whatever that Charlie bit my finger or
whatever but there's this set of videos
that were so funny to me and they're not
even that fun now that I go back and
look it's kind of like an old movie
where you're like dang this movie
doesn't it doesn't hold up it doesn't it
doesn't have the same juice like things
are much funnier now like the average
Tick Tock is funnier than the best
videos back in like 2006 which which
videos did you look at
uh okay this is gonna sound uh dumb but
have you ever seen this video uh you
know 12 year old boy uh disclaimer here
we go I visited this video of this cop
pulling over this guy he's got his hands
above his head it's like this yeah yeah
yeah and he goes he's patting them down
and he goes he goes all right let me
just check Pockets hold on here we go up
hey what what's this and the guy goes
that's my penis and he goes that's your
penis and then he continues
and this video cracks me up just the way
he goes That's What penis that's your
penis
and so there's that video but then
there's just a whole bunch of these that
were like just goofy videos yeah a lot
of them were like you know the news
anchors interviewing some like that kid
who's like I like turtles kid or like
the grape stomp video or like whatever
this is a whole bunch of these and I
watched like six of them and they just
cracked me up in this like where it's
like uh a simpler time
wife and a mortgage I didn't have it you
know it's just literally that was like
the those videos were just took me back
they just teleported me and so highly
recommend this this idea of flooding uh
you probably have done some version of
this on accident but like make it a
practice it's pretty awesome and it just
puts you in an amazing mood
this data is wrong every freaking time
have you heard of HubSpot
HubSpot is a CRM platform where
everything is fully integrated well I
can see the client's whole history calls
support tickets emails and here's a test
from three days ago I totally missed
club spot grow better
so I did it recently so I'm going to
tell a story that I you and I were
texting about and I can't reveal what I
was selling because it was kind of
against the law and I didn't know it at
the time but I told the statute of
limitations you're way past that it's
been more than 10 years
is that a real life
that's definitely a figure of speech
here's what we'll do we can mention I'll
I'll say it was alcohol that's all I
will say it was legal alcohol that I was
selling that's all I'm gonna say
um I was like anytime you have to
specify it was legal probably not a good
thing
so well so here's the story
I tweeted out that I think I it always
bothers me when people collect domain
names that's a that's a pet peeve
because I because I'm saying if you're
doing that you're doing the wrong stuff
because people say I'm gonna I've got
this great idea I'm gonna buy a domain
name or even worse I'll say I've got
this amazing domain name I should build
something for it I'm like dude don't
build something just because they have a
domain name so anyway I tweeted out I'm
like just make money first and just use
like a you know store
name.squarespace.com for like the
initial like hundred bucks in sales and
then go and get the domain name like and
someone's like you can't do that I was
like oh no I've done it a bunch of times
I'm like yeah well you're doing it
because you have a name it's like no I
didn't actually in college tons and tons
of times in fact I found this old
website that I had and it was
um alcohol name dot wordpress.com right
and I went and looked at the old stats
and it's getting 5 000 views a month
still on a wordpress.com free website in
this it's a store it's a quote a store
that is a blog post and a click to
PayPal and basically what I did was
there was this really unique drink that
was sold in Nashville and for some
reason only one or two stores were
carrying it but this particular type of
drink was popular across the country and
I thought well I should set up an online
store to sell this stuff and I did and I
made friends with the person selling it
the the liquor store or whatever and I
go hey I'm gonna sell this for 3x the
markup but I'll buy a bunch of it from
you so whatever and I did it and I
didn't I'm an idiot I didn't realize
that like as this thing was growing I
was making like a lot of money and I
went and told the legal team at my
college I was like hey I think my
business is like working really well do
I need to set up like an LLC or
something and they're like oh you're
breaking the law like you can't you
can't sell this without like a liquor
license I was like but it's like a
collect it's basically this thing that I
was telling it was it was a very rare
whiskey that was in a very particular
type of bottle that was like a
collector's item and I thought like it
was just like collectors item I don't
even know if people are gonna drink this
thing so anyway it was making like a
thousand dollars a day sometimes and I
looked at the old blog post that I was
selling this and it was hilarious and it
reminded me like
of a simpler time when I was sleeping on
a mattress on the floor yeah and life
was good and I was building motorcycles
in my living room and it was working out
well so I was like
building motorcycles in my living room
sleeping on the floor
collector's whiskey illegally on the
internet
it was a simpler time the American dream
the American dream I was one of those
kids that had you probably had this too
I didn't have beer like you remember
those college kids that would have like
beer cases the cardboard on their wall
yeah I wasn't that bad but I did have an
American flag I definitely had the
American flag so I was pretty trashy but
uh yeah I was so I was looking at my old
like blog that I used to do and I
couldn't even remember the password and
uh so I flooded myself a little
today
um the good thing is by the way this
whole if you're not watching on YouTube
You're missing half of it because Sam's
wearing a Harvard sweatshirt while we
tell these stories
we do we decided about someone illegal
whiskey waiting to poop
you made a bunch of jokes about the
south this is so stupid ugh oh my god
um all right I have something for you so
there's this company that's for sale
that I came across
so check it out go to chambers.com
Chambers okay yeah like that Harry
Potter stuff Chambers Chambers and
partners is that it yeah yeah okay okay
dude check this out so this website they
uh I think they're mostly in Europe but
they are in America as well is they put
out these rankings once a month or once
a quarter something like that and they
go and they interview lots of I think
they have 200 employees who do this 200
employees who go out and interview
different lawyers they talk to your past
clients
and they try to like see which cases
you're winning and it's all done
manually like there's not like a lot of
like Tech behind it and then they create
these rankings for like best legal firm
or whatever like that or like you know a
good firm for this good firm for that
like different niches and then they put
out these rankings and if you're a
lawyer you can pay money uh and and get
like a plaque they'll send you a plaque
and then also they'll allow you to use
their like thing in the in their like
when you send an email it could be like
voted a top lawyer by Chambers and you
could do and you could do all that dude
this company they do 44 million Euros or
yes or sorry 44 million pounds so what's
that in real real money that's like 60
million in revenue and then 18 million
in profit and they're selling right now
for close to 500 million dollars
it's a crazy company because I've been
for sale somewhere uh just like on a
trade magazine for uh media companies
that I follow it's like a small thing
called fashion Flames because this cut
that website they cover like B2B Media
stuff because I'm like been obsessed
with B2B database of the B2B media thing
Flash and flames.com I love it
it's like my favorite site I didn't even
want to tell people about it because I
like how you tried to just mutter it
it's a good one like I'm a paying
subscriber to it which is like
ridiculous uh but dude these lawyers pay
like 1500 to 4 000 a year
and they said they have like no churn
they're like we have we no insurance
from our from us because these lawyers
want it for so much these lawyers wanted
so much and I uh
am interested in this and I found like
eight or nine other businesses they call
them like data businesses or databases
or intelligence businesses and they're
not really much Tech but right now a lot
of them are selling for eight to ten
times revenue and I found 10 examples of
companies that have sold in the eight to
ten times Revenue range for one of these
data businesses it's ridiculous it's
crazy and this sounds like a scheme
um because what they do is they rank you
and then they go hey if you want like to
make like a special profile on our
website uh we'll do that and it's forty
five hundred dollars a year and what
we'll do is uh like once ranked you
could purchase this one pager where you
get a profile on our site it's almost
like a Wikipedia page where they like
one of the journalists just writes like
two paragraphs and it says like this
legal firm is known for X Y and Z and
then you could put that if you're a
lawyer you could put that in your email
signature and you're allowed to do that
and then people can click and see
whatever
it's crazy man this is a caper they're
pulling it off and I and I love stuff
like this you know it's like JD Power we
talked about you know how you know
they're smart because their logo is like
it looks like a medallion like a like it
looks like a special emblem or a ward
like it's a c with this like I don't
know what you call these but like the
pedals going around it
um yeah put this on the YouTube channel
so that people could see it but like a
reef it's yeah it's like it's like a
reef around it that like just looks like
you know what the Olympics in Athens
would would award their uh the top
performers right so like you you they're
they're really playing into the whole
thing with their brand uh so I think
that's pretty cool I have a business and
their name is Partners I'm gonna create
like something like this just do you
know Partners mayonnaise and partners
you know like we'll just do something
for the people you know we break we rank
best condiments mayonnaise and partners
I gotta figure this out and we can put
this on the logo but I love these rating
businesses what's the one you have
that's similar uh so I was have you ever
done like like uh trademark search
yourself
no what's that like when you start a
business and you want to look up is this
a good name what do you do do you pay a
lawyer and say hey can you just tell me
if this trademark's available do you do
that later once you get going I will do
that later once I get going is there is
there an importance to having a
trademark
yeah it's very hard to sell a company
without a trademark did you sell the
hustle without a trademark I didn't have
a trademark yeah typically uh it's very
hard to get acquired without owning your
name because it's a giant liability so
for example like if somebody else owns
the trademark
if you get six years in you're gonna
have to change your name because the
more valuable you get the bigger your
exposure is for them to say I own the
trademark this you have to change your
name or but maybe my name I mean it was
called The Hustle maybe it was too broad
of a name you know what I mean well I
don't know there's probably some troll
out there listen to this being like hey
hang on let me go get this guy so um
dude I'm past the Reps and warranty like
the SQL has been paid out so there's a
great uh there's a great
um story I think uh the early episode
where Moyes came on and told the native
story so it's like I don't know episode
10 of this podcast
um always tells a story about like when
they tried to sell native
um
they got in trouble with this so they go
they have a deal to sell native and as
they're doing the diligence or like as
they're prepping for the diligence
they're like we don't have the
trademark for Native uh Native
deodorants
and they're like okay well let's just
get it and they're like well you can't
get it because somebody else owns it
they're like what who owns data
deodorant there's no other native
deodorant look I have the domain and
they're like well no there's this guy
and I think it was like someone in Palo
Alto if I remember the story correctly I
might be butchering a little bit of this
but somebody in Palo Alto who was like
kind of like a patent troll type that
owned the name to it and owned a bunch
of names like this and they were like
and he's like okay I guess I can go buy
it off them because they're not doing
anything with it so he goes to them
tries to buy for like whatever 20K
they're like no so he's like okay yeah
whatever goes up 200k no
and like the guy wanted millions of
dollars for this name because he knows
your business is valuable you need this
name you're gonna change your brand name
for your consumer package good that's
like you know you can't change Doritos
to be called you know like like fluffies
you know tomorrow it doesn't work you
lose a lot of value and so they were
like going back and forth I forgot
exactly how he got resolved I think he
ended up buying it for two million or
something like that or voice did I think
so or
um
something else happened where they like
threatened to they were just like all
right screw you we're not going to do it
at all and the guy like realized it was
like his last ditch effort and like and
they ended up getting it for whatever
some amount um you know I forgot I
forgot what it was but they acquired it
in the end but yeah anyway so so I've
had this problem with the business of
mine which was that I up from I'm like
you I'm like oh I don't need a fancy
domain I don't need a fancy name let me
just start the business
and go and then I start and it goes and
it gets popular and then I'm like okay I
should probably like incorporate the
company and do like payroll and do like
all these things I should I you know I
should have been doing it important but
like I didn't wanna
do all that stuff if there wasn't like a
real business here and so then you try
to go back and some things are easier
than others to correct going backwards
one of the things that's hard to correct
is if you chose a name that wasn't right
you know you have a problem and so with
one of my businesses I had done the
actual search myself I should have just
paid a lawyer to do it but I went on the
USPTO search website which I don't know
if you've ever gone there but it's like
you know imagine like a government it's
like a DMV website and so you go there
you try to search and I search for our
brand name and nothing came up
but it turns out there's like a fancier
way to search where it's like yeah that
brand name or like with an S at the end
or like with Associated other words that
would make it too close and I didn't
know that and so I remember being so
frustrated with this interface and I was
like somebody should make a because this
is a it's a public database it's like
somebody should just make a more
consumer-friendly layer on top
and then I found a business that does
this and I got in touch with the guy who
does it so there's a business called
trademarkia.com so it's like trademark
with IA so trademarkia.com if you go to
it all of a sudden it's like like if you
just compare side by side like in the
YouTube channel you should do this like
take USPTO and try to find even where do
you go find search for trademarks and
then like how that looks versus this
where it just says search 11 million
trademarks for free
search your thing example Mickey Mouse
and it's like you can just type in your
brand name so like if I typed in you
know
the hustle
uh I'm gonna search for this and it's
gonna tell me what trademarks exists for
this who owns them this company kills it
what categories are there okay so so
HubSpot HubSpot owns it now so it says
the hustle hope saw owns it it's pending
and it was filed December 3rd 2022. when
did you sell uh December uh two years
ago what would that be 21 yeah so 20
okay wow so they yeah I didn't own it
they also it also looks like you
abandoned one in 2020
um so you know somebody did something on
your team maybe tried and didn't get it
or whatever it tells you what class it's
in et cetera et cetera so it's a great
great little thing and you can search
for like Associated names or whatever
it's a great website and so I reached
out to the guy who owns it I was like
dude this is uh and so I I said um
trademark is a great great idea
brilliant interface
um you know yeah props to you and he
goes uh so the guy lives in the Bay Area
actually and he goes yeah it's a really
cool website
um you know we have five million in AR
um and I can't you know if uh we've
never raised VC 5 million in ALR it was
kind of declining from the peak but I
just came back to the company removed
the subscription I got big plans now you
know I want to talk to you about it and
um you know he's gonna try to make this
like he wants to go for like the billion
dollar outcome and I was like dude I
think you have a five million dollar
your cash cow
um that you could probably get to like
eight or nine with just like some simple
tweaks and like you know chill like that
that sounds awesome
um but but I thought this is a really
cool website again it's just a simple
like these businesses are everywhere man
these businesses are hidden in plain
sight and in this case it took a public
data set it just put a much more
user-friendly wrapper on top versus what
you were talking about with Chambers is
they created their own data set and then
have then they owned that proprietary
data
it's called uh you know uh uh
who was it a non from CBM sites was on
and he was like no we just like taking
public data that's messy and we just
make it a little bit easier to yeah we
just make it clean
um by the way my first million is owned
by Advanced magazine Publishers which is
a big company in New York and it's a
entertainment services namely an online
non-downloadable video series featuring
star athletes explaining their life as
millionaires I guess that's that GQ
thing which I search or where I see when
I search on YouTube but uh anyway
badass I love this effect uh you wanna
I'm gonna go trademark this before this
episode comes out because now somebody's
gonna go squad on this
do you uh and um
a funny story about Native deodorant
I've always remembered this story I've
never brought it up to you so you and I
the hustle's office in twitch's office
was just a block or like 50 yards from
each other so if you know there's there
was like Kearney or whatever you were
and then you were the left if you go to
the right there was a little cafe that
was lovely that I that I really liked
and I believe Moyes the so native
deodorant is a company called uh Native
deodorant they sell deodorant it was
sold for a hundred million dollars in in
cash and it probably does hundreds of
millions now and it has like a really
cute branding they make shampoo they
make everything
and I remember walking by this lovely
Cafe and I thought huh this Cafe is
called native too and their logo looks
just like native deodorant and I
realized that Moyes worked nearby uh and
so I put kind of two and two together so
if you Google native Co SF yeah you'll
see a little you'll see a little cafe uh
you'll see their Yelp page they've
changed their logo to uh green but it
used to be yellow or sorry it used to be
blue the exact same as native deodorant
and so I have a feeling that he was just
thinking branding by this and I was like
this is I remember thinking dude boys
they're ripping off your brand or are
you doing it exactly and now it's
realized the obvious he was like so all
right I need a name looked out the
window saw it it was like that's my name
and my logo now
that's mine if you go to this go if you
look up native facing is exactly the
same it's exactly the same and it used
to be blue it looked like they're like
they look like Nivea blue it was it was
the white background with the same blue
and now it's green it looks like they
closed in covet and they moved to a new
location but that old location that we
were at it was the same logo and it was
called native Co and I think Native
deodorant was the domain was also native
code for him
yes it was it was the exact same thing
and so he must have been just walking
down the street and he goes like yep
that's me that's mine now you know it's
just like there's that Meme on the
internet of like a stick figure handing
an item to another stick figure saying
hey I made this and the second stake a
figure looks at it goes I made this
that's basically what just happened and
uh I don't think I've ever like said
this to him but I would love to hear
what his rebuttal is but he 100
stole the entire branding the name
everything from this company I don't
know if stealing's the right word but
kinda I mean that one looks like
stealing it looks like he actually went
took a screwdriver took off took their
sign off their office moved it across
the street and put it on his office it's
the exact logo I remember seeing that
for years and being like huh and I just
never like put two and two together I
didn't realize he worked there but I was
like wow they're really ripping off his
branding
no that's that Cafe has been there for
years I remember walking by it for years
well now they're shut down that's that I
mean this is like everything that's
wrong in society
um you know he sells his business for
100 million dollars poor Cafe you know
shuts down uh you know you know sadly
during covet during the pandemic yeah
this is the way the world is going dude
have you seen people ripping us off I
don't know if you've seen this but no
but that's cool in the next two weeks
you're gonna see Twitter threads
linkedins short videos on Tick Tock
other podcasts talking about the exact
same stories that we tell here there's
like this group of 10 people that just
take our content
and then they just exact same thing and
they just tell that exact same story
they're gonna be like dude Dave Ramsey
Dave how Dave Ramsey built a 600 million
dollar Empire animation this that and
they're just gonna be like literally
steal our stick it's it's kind of
annoying I get it uh Michael from our
future has done it a few times yeah they
do yeah he's one of the ten that that
does this all the time who are the other
nine uh I mean I don't even really want
to give them shine of of doing that you
know this is literally if you're one of
those people just you know this is this
have your own silent embarrassment
there's nothing wrong like taking ideas
and remixing them uh but what most
people do is they just take the same
idea they just tell the same story uh
the same way that we already told it in
their own Twitter thread or their own
LinkedIn and and whatever else
um which is fine but like give credit at
least if you're gonna if you're gonna
say the same thing be like oh I was
listening to my first million and they
told this great story
check it out all right now yeah that
that's I think a slightly better way to
do it
um
but you know whatever it is it is but
this is why so I have a new project I'm
actually going to announce it in about a
month or three weeks this is why I
didn't announce it I've been working on
this for almost a year now I didn't want
to announce it copycats everyone
everyone talks about building public I
hate building in public building in
public is not cool when you're popular
building in public is really cool when
you want to get popular yeah exactly but
once you already have a following I
don't want to do it like the milk Road
did you guys have a bunch of copycats
yeah yeah tons uh there's like
there's tons of embarrassing ones that
are out there uh there's like people
that literally just took the same exact
newsletter and they would some people
would translate it so they're like oh
I'm you know leche leche whatever and
it's like the Mexican milk Road and then
they would translate it to Spanish and
just like Google translate and then
publish
um there's another one that uh there's
one I don't know if I want to put this
guy on blast but
um someone who tried to buy the milk
Road and failed yeah I know then just
tried to copy it in his own like way and
you could just the funny thing is they
very rarely work
um they don't and it's like kind of
surprising why don't they where I kind
of expected them to work
um like for example when people take our
content and then write a thread about
our LinkedIn like it does pretty good
like that that kind of works for them
otherwise they wouldn't really keep
doing it but the copy the whole
newsletter thing like for some reason
that doesn't really work I'm not sure
I'm not 100 sure I'll explain why I know
why do you want to know the so basically
if for people who have been raised on
the internet they have a very high
detector and you want to know
the best way to circumvent someone's
detector
now don't you don't
don't that's how you circumvent
that detector you don't
and people can sniff this out
and so if they read something and it's
like dude you're like a not cool older
guy trying to act like a cool younger
person I know that this is not good like
this doesn't work I told you about the
uh nqr right the the KFC's in China not
quite right it's like dude it's the same
menu like this is this is the spicy
chicken sandwich and it's like
that's not quite right and people it
just doesn't taste right the taste buds
reject it now
I believe that when it comes to if I use
one product and then somebody tries to
copy it I'm like why would I want this
shitty copy I'm just going to keep going
with the original but in markets where
you're reaching a new audience or people
who haven't heard of the original I'm
surprised it doesn't work and I think my
theory of why it doesn't work in those
cases I think you're right when it's uh
when people have tasted the original
that they don't really want the the
or when it's like uh community community
brand uh like personality driven you
know it's it's that one moat that Peter
Thiel doesn't understand brand
yeah
the one the Asperger proof uh yeah
defense
uh weapon we have so you know the one
thing that I think is is true which is
like this like Iceberg Theory which is
which is like if you look at an iceberg
like the part you see at the top is like
you know five percent of the total mass
that's there and so what I think people
get wrong when they try to copy a
business is that they only see the top
the five percent and they're like okay
I'm gonna copy that but they don't know
what goes on underneath they don't know
that basically the uncopyable thing is
the the people the personalities the
engine underneath that's coming up with
the creative ideas that's coming up with
the next marketing thing because this
one starts to decline and so I think
that's the part that's typically hard to
copy but honestly I'm surprised that
more of them don't work because if
you're sufficiently talented I think I
think it
sadly does work more often than it
doesn't
we should do an episode where we talk
about the things that people have copied
and it's become better than the original
um like there's stories of the samware
brothers so it's these three brothers in
Germany and they have the company called
Rocket internet and it was a clone
Factory and they basically it's a it was
publicly traded until recently but the
reason they started this company was
they like cloned Amazon and all these
other companies Zappos Uber things like
that but before they started company
started that company they cloned other
things and they sold it to the original
so they cloned eBay in Germany and they
sold it back to eBay for 90 million
dollars in like three months and then
they were going to do the same thing
with Groupon but they got bigger than
Groupon and they realized oh wow once
you get huge this business sucks we
gotta offload it and then they try to do
that with Zappos the shoe company but
they got bigger than the original Zappos
so the bigger they were their market cap
was larger so they couldn't sell it and
they uh like this is their whole
strategy it's a very fascinating
strategy and so far it's not panned out
for them other than like hello fresh
they did hello fresh and they copied
blue apron and hellofresh worked right
yeah I think
there's an art there's an art to copying
this is a whole whole I think we could
do a whole podcast about like if you're
gonna copy here's how to do it here's
how to do it in a way that feels good to
your soul feels good to customers
actually works and is not just going to
result in like a massive waste of time
and so I think there's there's a bunch
of different little factors there I
think one thing the Samoa brothers did
one of the factors for example is they
um
they
did the same business in a different
country and so I think you know
Geographic Geographic differentiation is
important
um I think that's one that that that you
can you can copy and make things work
when you do Geographic difference uh but
then there's some traps with that too
that we could we could talk about but um
all right where do you want it where do
you want to finish up I think we should
well
there is one thing that we should do
and yeah I forgot about that so you're
aware of it I think I'm aware of it I
can't seem to find my pen but I need
it's okay you don't need you don't need
a pen so basically but I thought I
decided something some sort of you do
but you you sign it but just with a
click of a button so basically at this
podcast my first million our content
unlike every other content on YouTube
it's actually not for free right not a
free podcast it's not a free podcast
because what you have to do if you've
seen one more than one episode you have
to do this thing called The Gentleman's
Agreement which is it's called that
because we're not there I'm not behind
you to stare at your screen that's why
honor the gentleman's agreement it's an
honor code you have to basically go and
uh click subscribe on YouTube because
we'll get more subscribers that helps
the algorithm we get more views and then
we'll do more dumb stuff for you so it's
called the gentleman's agreement if
you've watched more than one video you
have to do this everyone's doing it I
have a addendum to the gentleman's
agreement came from a from a listener
she pointed it out she goes not only
have I signed the gentleman's agreement
I've signed the ladies understanding and
what's the lady's understanding you know
there's not many phrases that will stop
me in my tracks but I was stopped in my
tracks the lady's understanding I
thought that was phenomenal the lady's
understanding that's actually when you
also click subscribe on the iTunes or
the I always call iTunes on the podcast
app and the Spotify app understanding go
that extra mile and give us the ladies
understanding along with the gentleman's
screen since we started doing this so
two things about gentlemen's remake
number one it's funny because we're
talking about copying you stole this
stick from somebody dude I stole it and
he called me by the way and he was like
isn't that awesome it works so good and
he invited me to go to a UFC fight and
you did it right because you gave credit
to him uh you put your own spin on it
and uh yeah you credited him most
importantly as being like this guy did
this awesome thing and I was like wow I
I gotta try doing this
um so you know you credited him and
that's cool that you guys are are going
to see a fight together that's that's
amazing now it's cute the second thing
is we have grown a lot since we did this
so we started doing this we were at 100
would you the first time you did it I
believe we had 145 000 subscribers on
YouTube it was like a month ago we have
yeah that was like yeah maybe 45 days
ago something like that and now we're at
180 000. and the people who watch the
Youtube videos they know this in fact
I'm looking at a tweet right now which
he goes he goes he just mentioned us he
goes watching on YouTube is better than
Spotify but yeah no I told you this
it is way better to
want to and in fact what I think we
should do to really like juice the
agreement to even add more you know see
appendix a of the gentleman's agreement
I think we should do a piece of content
that is only good when you watch it so
so here's my here's my proposal to you
Sam I think we should do basically like
shirtless yeah
Sam's gonna be shirtless and I'm gonna
scream chair
but I think we should feature us going
through like a pitch deck and making
taking one from average to awesome or
like good to Great uh and just show how
we would tweak the copy how we would
make it look like better and we'll use a
real one and so I think we should do
that and put that only on the YouTube
channel because it would only make sense
to see it no I think that on YouTube
you should log into chase.com
and uh show show your checking account
okay and it will react but we won't say
the number that's genius you know this
is why you complete me bro
I gave you a shitty idea
you gave me the old yes and
we're gonna go to chase.com or whatever
Bank of America whatever you use and
you're gonna just we're gonna watch you
log in and we're just gonna react and
that's it by the way the yes and is the
corniest thing that the startup World
tried to take from from like the cool
like you know people who are actually
funny world because actually it's a no
but
this is what you just did there no but
we should do this instead is a better
amount of people
and improv people are are one step below
a cappella people in terms of the Nerds
so like there's no way we're cool and
improv people you ever been around an
improper sense like being around someone
who does CrossFit you know like just
stop talking about it I can't stand
improv people they're exhausting it's
like uh
people without muscle uh dude said it's
like uh it's like a blind Jack Russell
you know what those are it's like that
dog that's yapping everywhere and when
it's blind you just can't stop it's
going all over the place that's what I
feel about an improp person yeah I think
you're I think you're right I did improv
so I can confirm this is correct
um and you're correct that it's below
acapella which is below anything that's
actually cool
yeah
Apollo is the worst of the worst I
remember hanging out with people from
New England and they like were bracking
about acapella and I was like dude shut
up why are you talking about that you
don't want people to know and uh people
hang out with each other and they're
like ordering or they're like waiting
for their food at the table and then one
guy's like
and then it's like
um
harmonizing it's like dude you gotta
stop like you know if I hear The Lion
King sorry one more time I'm gonna put a
bullet in my head that's how I feel but
when I'm with these people
if I'm ever trapped on a subway and like
they do a flash mob around me start
singing
are above last month people are are
above the acapella I'm gonna do
something I'm gonna start vomiting just
out outrageous them
that's the pod
foreign
[Music]